what's the longest skype call you guys
have ever been in
together or just just in general i think
it was the one with her where i was i
was in a skype call for like
12 hours yeah 12 hours and then after
that i think
uh when time came like you went you
finally got back to australia and then
we gave it time to think and we're like
and we were both blowing up
around like the same time and then our
channels were yeah
sorry sorry i can't hear the word flying
out without thinking about that meme but
that guy's like when i blow up
i don't know
when our careers were like finally
taking off we just kind of got in a talk
and said this isn't going to work
and we're too busy and i don't know i
feel like well it's also because i was
in my last year of uni at the time and i
was
stressed out of my [ __ ] mind because
i'm like if i don't knuckle down on this
[ __ ] i'm not gonna graduate
yeah i've been playing corpse party 18
hours yeah yeah i can't i can't
i can't be doing free translations for a
corpse party visual novel like i
a [ __ ] knuckle down so like so that
was like so at that point like
i not only like ghosted you i i ghosted
everyone
watching yeah yeah i like it like three
months last year the last year of uni do
be like that yeah
yeah so and then in the meanwhile i was
just kind of doing my own thing fast
forward though
ax comes around and then we both message
each other
and uh i think that was also like my
samurai buyer video had just come out
that day and that's when you dm oh good
old samurai buyer
and then uh i was uh i guess we just got
like this private talk but i was just
like
okay yeah we're going to ax um i'll see
you there
and so we met and yeah i guess it was ax
2016. i think so
yeah that was that was like i think
watching you guys at ax this is before
we even like did we speak at that point
i think so
we spoke but we had to admit i think so
that was when i was like
i don't care i'm going to ax next year i
felt so left out seeing how much fun it
was
it was that ax yeah
i think 2016. yeah because you've been a
few times before me right yeah that's
right yeah 2016 was the first year i met
you
and jeff yeah yeah that's right but i
think i'd gone to one before that i
don't know if anyone else had went
that's gone no
twenty-two first one i've gone to ax
like every year since i was like 13.
i'm so jealous so you've seen so you've
seen the scene
evolve over time it's honestly just been
so [ __ ] great like it's uh it was the
first year you went
like what you i can't i don't even know
i actually i i i
remember like how old you were roughly i
was maybe
almost 14 or 15. oh my god
yeah i was 14 or 15. my first and acts
yeah not even like 2010 and that was
back then where like the line was big
but it went by
fast like day zero wasn't a problem yeah
now seeing it nowadays like i
loathe daisy like i don't mind yeah yeah
yeah
line con basically so yeah i know it's
been crazy to see
um like just kind of the progression of
things and i used to watch videos of ax
uh back in 2007 and if you look at any
vlogs of ax of 2007
they will say oh my god it's like so
packed here literally it's just like the
it's like 3 000 people yeah but that was
a lot back then you know
i mean it's it's the pd flow videos that
you yeah because i watched exactly the
same thing
because i remember back in who is this
so okay so oh sorry no go for it okay so
it's basically a guy who
seemed to be very influenced by kasim g
like some you know
old youtubers but what he would
basically do is just he would go around
ax
every year and just vlog it and do
interviews and slightly yeah in the cmg
kind of style
and me trying to point them out to be
kind of like yeah yeah yeah exactly and
me
as a weeb growing up in like the mid
2000s
never been to a convention in my life
and especially the uk
exactly especially in the uk scene
seeing these vlogs this was like mecca
to me you know
i i remember watching these vlogs and i
remember thinking i'm gonna be there one
day
i'm gonna be there one day it was legit
like the greatest thing i had ever seen
in my life like okay by the way if you
guys ever want to look at him petey flow
i don't know if you're still around
watching this
but it's like p-e-p-e-e it'll be
not okay p literally p d yeah
looking at the ax vlogs i was like this
is blowing my [ __ ]